hey everyone quincy larson here with
free code camp
i am thrilled today to introduce the
2021
data science curriculum expansion this
is going to be
massive we've been working on it for
several
months like planning and this is
actually something that i've wanted to
do for years
we're going to teach new certifications
in mathematics
data science and machine learning and
in order to teach these complicated
hierarchical topics
we are going to have to pull out all the
stops
and roll out some really cool new
learning experiences
first of all i want to remind everybody
that we are
raising money to be able to bring on
some additional
instructional staff so that we can
design these curricula
there are a lot of topics that we
ourselves
have expertise on for example beau has
written
an entire course from manning that's
focused on deep learning
so he knows a lot about neural networks
and things like that but
we don't have as much expertise in like
supervised learning or unsupervised
learning we don't have a lot of
expertise in teaching calculus
or linear algebra so we're really
looking for some computer science
professors and some mathematics
professors who do have
experience when we can bring on to help
design some of
some of those projects so
if you decide that you're willing to
donate to our nonprofit if you're
already donating five dollars a month as
one of the seven thousand people who
supports our nonprofits mission
fantastic you don't have to donate but
if you do want to donate
we would absolutely welcome it uh and
the big the big news is daryl silver
is matching all donations 100
uh up to 150 000 so if you give a
hundred dollars
it's gonna be like you gave two hundred
dollars because daryl's gonna give a
hundred dollars as well
to match that one hundred dollars that
you gave uh and
of course free code camp is a donor
supported nonprofit
501c3 tax exempt which means that
there's a good chance that you'll be
able to deduct this from your taxes
depending on which country you live in
as well and i can get you a donation
receipt for that
so be sure to make a donation
to our nonprofit for this very specific
purpose of us helping build this new
curriculum now i'm going to talk about
the curriculum
there's quite a bit to cover and there
are going to be a few demos so bear with
me
first what is the
current curriculum what does it look
like well the curriculum
represents a shortest path to getting a
developer job
and here's our landing page let's go to
the curriculum section here
and just because we can let's switch to
the night mode so it'll be a little
easier on the eyes
um so uh after this
nice uh inspirational quote we're gonna
see that
the current curriculum is mostly web
development
and we do have some python development
in here
but we're going to dramatically expand
this so what is the new curriculum going
to look like
well uh first thing to note is that
the curriculum is a line it's
linear we're not trying to introduce
branching paths
we really like i personally strongly
believe that data science is kind of a
natural progression
after you've worked as a developer you
go back you learn some additional math
you learn some
additional skills um and and then
you know you can become a data scientist
and and if you
really really want to get into it you
can become like a machine learning
engineer
and you're going to learn even more math
for that but
the logical hopping off points for being
able to go out and get
a developer job i would say you can go
and get one of the full stack
development jobs out there about
half of all developer jobs are web
development jobs
and if you're a full stack developer you
should be able to do pretty much
anything
uh you may need to learn some new skills
on the job but this will give you
a general framework with which you can
learn and so that's responsible web
design
uh javascript algorithms data structures
front and libraries
there's a new certification that we're
creating that we're very proud of that
we're going to demo
in just a few minutes where you're in vs
code and you've got
a command line and you're you're
basically learning bash
and sql and postgres and get and
and lots of linux commands interactively
very cool in vs code in a browser on
freecodecamp
so uh tom's gonna demo that in a minute
then
apis and microservices quality insurance
information security
all really important uh web development
concepts
then uh if you wanna stick around
or if you've already got a web
development job and you want to expand
your skills
data science we
use the python ecosystem extensively
it's very powerful
you can do pretty much everything in
python that you need to do with data
science
and it's growing very fast there's this
huge critical mass
of talent that's contributing to the
python ecosystem
uh so uh we're gonna teach scientific
computing with python then we're going
to
get into the foundational math and the
way we're teaching math
is within jupiter notebooks eric is
going to demo what that looks like
in just a moment but basically we've got
tests that run within
jupiter notebook and you'll be able to
basically learn math by coding you'll
take
mathematical expression you'll implement
that in code and you'll work with code
instead of like the way you might
traditionally cross things out with a
pen and paper and
move things around there's a lot of
value in that too but we're going to
assume
that people are busy adults they don't
have time
to go back to school and learn the way
you would learn math
in like primary secondary school
they want to just jump in and learn it
in the most practical
time effective way in a way that's
integrated with the contemporary tools
we have
nowadays like unless you're out on like
a desert island you probably have access
to some kind of computer that may be
very powerful
that you can use to do math and so it's
it's
less about knowing how to do math by
hand and more about knowing how to
use computers to get whatever you need
done now that still involves you
understanding the concepts and and we're
going to
teach you those concepts we're going to
drill on those heavily through a series
of tons of very rigorous projects
but the way you're going to learn math
is going to be a little bit faster than
going back
and learning you know 12 years of math
and then
some university level math as well
instead you're just going to
jump straight into it but this will
assume that you haven't done math
since high school um and that you may
have not even done that much of math in
high school that's how basic we're going
to start here so we're going to do
foundational mathematics then we're
going to get into algorithmic problem
solving
you'll be able to take the math you've
learned and apply it to learning
you know greedy algorithms uh divide and
conquer algorithms
uh dynamic programming things like that
then
we get into the real workhorse of data
science which is statistics
and here we're going to teach you in the
discrete statistics section
all the statistics you can learn without
actually knowing calculus
and then we're going to turn around and
apply that data engineering
exploratory data analysis with this
you'll probably have
the basic data science skills that you
need to be able to
go to a small business or start up and
and start gleaning insights from their
data as a data scientist
but if you want to work for like a
government or like a giant corporation
that has
tons of data big data is
they used to call it i don't know if
they still call it that but like lots of
data essentially like
uh you know american express level data
or visa level data
or uh you know the irs level data or
something like that right
like those kinds of data sets nasa or
cern
data you're going to need a lot more
than that uh you're going to need to
know
calculus so that's the first thing we're
going to teach you in the advanced data
science section which is
you know single multivariable calculus
then we're going to get into the
advanced
probability of statistics you can learn
once you know calculus
then we're going to learn linear algebra
and matrix algebra which are very useful
for doing machine learning and then of
course machine learning itself we're
going to cover all three
big branches of machine learning
supervised learning unsupervised
learning
reinforcement learning so if you're
counting that's like 19
certifications each of those takes about
300 hours a
conservative estimate uh in in practice
we had one person who went through six
different certifications
they speed ran it and it was a
experienced developer forum pop he speed
ran
the entire like six certification
curriculum in
29 days that's
that's about as fast as you can probably
do it and this is three times that
so uh you're gonna be hard-pressed to
get through this within
even a few years i think most likely
you're going to be coming to
back to free code camp after you've been
working and you're going to continue to
extend
your skills and that's what learning is
all about it should be lifelong learning
you know
so you're going to be able to put this
lifelong learning in action with a
massive curriculum
that uh will continue to help you grow
as a developer
so let's let's take a look at what the
curriculum actually entails
just to give you an idea the level of
specificity
and autonomy that we've broken it down
to from pronouncing those words
correctly
uh so like this is the web development
curriculum this is just a quick
curriculum sheet
that shows you like all the different
topics we're covering for like
uh this is just for the responsive web
design
certification but you can see we we make
it
very granular we cover things in extreme
detail because
not only do we want to cover them but we
want a lot of repetition so you're
you're applying and then later you're
reapplying and you're reapplying
and you're building lots of different
projects to uh
apply your skills and then we you know
this sheet which
i i have a link to by the way down uh in
the description if you if you want to
visit this
yourself um you know if you go over to
for for example uh the relational
database certification which you're
going to see a demo
of in a minute uh we've got like all the
different bash commands
then we want to go through all the
different uh
a lot of them sql postgres
uh yeah so you're gonna learn all these
different commands all these different
concepts and then you're just gonna keep
applying them
over and over through all these projects
over here and another cool thing we're
doing is we're taking the certification
projects and instead of having five
certification projects at the end of the
certification
we're gonna have like level level boss
battle level level boss battle
we're gonna try to have it like mix up
the uh proverbial gameplay a little bit
um so you'll have kind of like
hand-holding
tutorials where each each step takes you
know maybe a minute or two to get
through
and then you're gonna have like big
ambiguous challenges where it might take
you
a few hours to be able to figure out how
to build this project
uh both are very valuable um and and
again we've got like all these different
certifications
mapped out with their varying degrees of
uh um
you know development but like you know
for example reinforcement learning
neural networks and stuff
uh markov chains stuff like that you're
gonna have a lot of fun with this
so this again is
in the link below uh so at this point i
want to hand it over
to um over to eric who's gonna demo what
the free code camp
learning experience is like for
mathematics uh
inside jupiter notebook before i do that
though i just want to remind you one
more time
we are raising funds we we budget
about three hundred thousand dollars to
bring on some instructors
to focus on this intently and it's
probably going to take about two years
so this is the budget for two years for
bringing on a couple of math math
instructors
maybe three or four depending on whether
how many of them are doing part time a
lot of
uh instructors work they're teaching you
know they
they work a lot of different schools so
we just like to build a really
strong team of people who have expertise
not just
in these fields but in teaching these
fields uh to help us
build out these curricula so with that
i'm gonna hand it over to eric
eric's gonna show what the pi the
jupiter notebook experience looks like
take it away eric
hi y'all eric here so with this little
demo
here i want to give you a glimpse of
what studying math will look like on
feedco camp
and so by the end of this i hope i can
convince you that
although math is hard we can make it a
little less intimidating and more
interactive
along with teaching you about some tools
that allow you to experiment with math
similar how you would in programming
and so here we have a little problem
that you might experience
in say an algebra class you might have
so here we want to solve this system of
equations
and we want to return the answer as
senpai equations and so senpai is the
library we'll
use to help us manipulate
and solve math equations using python
and our computer
so here's the little basic uh
solution for it or at least where we'll
start with so here we're just going to
import some important libraries i might
use
and then we're going to put a lot of our
work into this main function
and then the last bit of lines of code
here will just show us our answer
so what if we run this what do we get
so i'm going to run this so just run
this cell and it's going to output some
stuff
so here we're just outputting the
equations themselves
and so this is just showing that we can
encode
the math equations from above in python
so you notice that they are
same and so we can do that here on this
line
where we create an equation using the eq
function in simpli and then we just
define the left
and then the right side of our equations
okay so say you had your code ready to
go
and you want to test to see if you got
it right
and so in this notebook we have some
testing code that's hidden a little bit
but you can test your code by going to
cell and running all
so we're going to run and see these
equations again
and if you scroll down a little bit
you'll get this uh
text here that'll show you your code is
run and tested
so you there's a lot of text here but i
would focus on
every um other lineup of those output
so here here's one test uh you should
have a function ex that was defined
and so we had that so our test says okay
and then you can notice that some of
these tests did fail because we didn't
pass some of those tests that we might
have
to see if our code is correct okay so
to to try to solve this equation without
taking too much time
i'm just going to paste in an example
solution here so we can put our work in
the middle
so here we're just redefining each of
these equations
and doing uh mathematical operations
on each of the left and right hand sides
and so not only can you add and subtract
numbers like we have here
we can even and subtract variables so as
a way for you to test
and experiment with math that you um
with this
so so this is so let's run this
okay so similar in math we want to show
our steps
and so one thing you could do is just
display your answers and so here we can
see
our equations nicely formatted and in
the end
we get our answers as x is equal to
three and y is equal to
six so perfect so now
let's run our cells again
see if we are tests are good so we
scroll down a bit
and what do you know so all our tests
are now looking good
and we get an okay at the end
so one quick demonstration of some
other features of senpai so we can also
plot our results and see what
those results might be so here
is some code to do that so i'm going to
plot
the same equations that we had before to
run that
have that run and so here's a visual
representation
of what that equation is and so it gives
us another idea
of the equation the answers that we got
and trying to
link that with how we might actually
plot that as well
then one last thing i want to show with
the the power of senpai
and python is that say we had all these
equations
and we wanted to double check our
answers
and so senpai actually has a way to
solve these equations
for us and so this may be powerful way
for more advanced math users to save a
little bit of time but also
for newer learners of math to try to
have some tools to
help them find out what is the finish
line
to a problem and then try to make steps
in between to figure out what their math
and to correct their math rather to get
to the right answer
so i've placed in some code that'll do
this for us
so i won't get into too much detail of
some of the
equation uh functions we're using but
this last line here is the one that will
actually solve our equation
and when we run this we get our output
as the same answer as we got before
so with this little demo i hope i've
inspired you to look at math a little
bit differently
and that you may have some fun
programming some math
so thank you welcome back thank you very
much eric for
demoing that it's really impressive uh
eric's been
doing a lot of the hard critical
thinking on this
figuring out how to implement all this
stuff figuring how
we can use jupiter notebook and we're
going to try to
host an entire cluster of jupiter
notebook
servers so that people can do these
exercises right on free code camp we've
already got
kind of a cluster going and we're load
testing it to see if we can actually
afford
to uh to host everything ourselves uh if
not we've got some fallback plans
uh but jupiter notebook the entire
python
community like huge shout outs to them
they're doing so much
to make it easier to learn in the
browser and
you know jupyter notebook is not just a
learning tool it's an industrial grade
tool that like data scientists use all
the time to do their work so you're
going to be using the same tools
to uh learn that you're going to be
using when you're actually in the field
and speaking of tools that are used in
the field by far the most
widely used text code editor
at least here at freecodecamp like
everybody on the team uses vs code and i
think a lot of people on the field are
using vs code now
there are plenty of other good ides but
vs code is great and it's
it's growing pretty steadily in adoption
you're going to be able to build
your full stack projects in vs code
on freecodecamp.org you're going to have
access to a file system a command line
you know all that all that stuff that
you would be able to have if you were
developing locally so
tom is going to tell us all about that
he's going to demo some of the
relational database certification
take it away tom this is what some of
our upcoming lessons are going to look
like
we have the s code running inside of a
vm
which is running inside the browser so
you can take advantage of all the tools
vs code has like this
integrated terminal or
install anything we want to be in pretty
much like python or
sql databases
and in this tutorial you'll be writing a
bash program that interacts with
postgres so i'm just going to go through
some of the lessons
and show you what it's all about this
first one
is to log in to the shell here
and you just hit enter and the tests are
on automatically
and then you can move on to the next one
so we're going to list the databases to
see what databases are here
and those are the databases that are
there
the first chunk of this tutorial is
building out the database structure
and adding some information to it and
then
sort of the second part is to
build the script then to interact with
it and it's a little program where you
kind of enter a menu option and
rent a bike out and return likes i guess
so for this first part we're just
building out the database structure and
the third lesson i think is to create a
database
named likes
and once you write and to enter the
right command you can
move on to the next lesson then we will
list the databases to make sure it got
created and then we will connect
to the database to start adding things
and then we will create table
bikes for the inventory
and we will display the table to make
sure it got created
and we will add a column
and bike id
that is the primary key
and then we will
look at the details of our table
so there's a lot of like back and forth
of kind of creating something or doing
something and then
you know viewing it in the database
so it's very interactive and i think
it's a great way to learn
so after you have created your database
and added all your
rows this is where you start creating
your script
and what you're going to do is open a
second terminal so you have one here to
interact with the database directly
and one where you can run your script
and do other things
um and so we're just going to create a
file
for our script
and then we are going to open it up so
we can start building
[Music]
and then we get some nifty little add
your code
hints right here
and we will echo this
title
and then we're gonna change the
permissions
so it's executable
and then we're gonna run it and see what
happens
all right next lesson here is to just
create a function
and then we're gonna echo out
oh may i help
and then we are going to run the script
there it is
pretty cool
this is one of the certification
projects
all you need to do is uh build out a
database
according to all these user stories down
here
and that's the whole project
i'm going to see if i can get one or two
of them done so i'm just gonna log in
here
create my database
i'm gonna test and there i get it got
one done
um next i need to connect
and create my tables
all right thank you very much tom that
was fantastic and
i just want to thank everybody who stuck
around this long
this is something we've been planning
and
working on for this point more than a
year
and this fundraiser is a critical part
of us being able to afford to bring on
instructors and really expedite the
creation of these resources
if we are able to raise these funds and
bring on these instructors we'll be able
to build this so much faster
again i think we'll be able to have some
early versions of
all these certifications out within 2021
and then uh steadily refine them through
2022
and beyond uh if we don't manage to
raise these funds
i mean it could take far longer than
that because it probably has to do with
our existing team
and we do have people on our team who
have expertise
with machine learning but it's it's
going to be a pale shadow of what it
could be
if we're able to raise these funds so
again daryl silver is generously
matching
100 any donations you make so be sure to
click the link below
and go over and just donate whatever you
can afford
to free code camp it means so much to us
i'll get you a tax receipt
i'll give you a receipt for your taxes
and everything just send me an email
and uh we would again we'd be over the
moon if we can make this work
uh we're a small donor supported
nonprofit we're extremely capital
efficient we're going to put these
funds to very responsible use and we're
going to build
a free learning resource that people
around the world will be able to use
for free in their browsers at their
convenience over many years to come
so thank you very much for your time
thank you for the faith that you've put
in our community and everything you all
are doing
to be a part of the community to help
one another
to learn to spread knowledge to spread
the desire to learn
all of these things are absolutely
critical to
free coking's mission of helping you
know teach people about technology
thank you